foreign
those experts range from International
artists and
mathematician seeking to navigate the
convergence of art Science Tech and the
natural world
foreign
[Music]
borderless and he says advancements and
technology has been the key to Greater
freedom of expression
from experimenting with interactive
installations to having visitors step
into water teamlab has wound people all
over the world in more than 50 cities
one of its most tucked away museums can
be found in a forest in southern Japan
team Labs digitize nature project
explores how digital Tech can turn
nature into art without harming it is
you know
teamlab has no plans to slow down set to
open a new Museum in Abu Dhabi focus on
the concept of environmental phenomena
slated to open in 2024
koshuki says digital technology has made
it possible for artworks to expand
physically which allows for manipulating
and using much larger spaces that way
viewers are able to experience the
artwork much more directly now and in
the future
[Music]